[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti Come avete sentito mi
chiamo Veronica di quattro di quattro e
fin da piccola questo cognome era
oggetto di simpatiche prese in giro
quattro chiacchiere Quattro Gatti ma
quella più bella all'appello di quattro
colpiti affondata
quindi forse che proprio perché nome
nome i numeri sono sempre stati una
parte fondamentale della mia vita
personale e professionale i numeri Mi
piacciono li ho studiati ci lavoro e mi
piace pensare di avere una mente
matematica
Quindi quando ho avuto l'opportunità di
venire qui oggi a parlarvi di disruptive
la mia reazione immediata è stata è
possibile trovare un collegamento fra i
numeri e l'ambizione anzi ancora meglio
è possibile identificare quelli che sono
alcuni elementi che compongono
l'ambizione rappresentarli dal punto di
vista matematico e arrivare a definire
Addirittura una formula dell'ambizione
Ecco ve lo dico subito mi dispiace
deludervi e una vera e propria formula
dell'ambizione No non ci sono riuscita
secondo me non esiste però sono riuscita
a identificare alcuni elementi che
compongono piuttosto un insieme di
funzioni che possono aiutarci a capire
meglio la natura dell'ambizione ed ecco
oggi Voglio condividere con voi proprio
quello che è stata la mia esperienza
durante la mia vita professionale
dell'ambizione e come sono arrivata a
definire alcuni di questi elementi
sono partita da una riflessione tempo fa
parlando con un responsabile delle
risorse umane della mia azienda stavamo
valutando due candidati e uno veniva
definito come troppo ambizioso senza
scrupoli e l'altro l'esatto contrario il
primo era stato troppo assertivo sulla
crescita finanziaria dell'azienda e
l'altro aveva parlato solo della sua
famiglia e degli aspetti personali
interessante ho pensato quindi c'è un
troppo e un troppo poco e come facciamo
quindi a capire qual è l'equilibrio
giusto
rivolgiamoci per un attimo
all'etimologia della parola ambizione
viene dal latino ambizio che è formato
da una parte da ambi inteso come tutte
le direzioni e dall'altra dal participio
passato del verbo eo itum Che significa
andare
quindi ambizione inteso come non
rimanere fermo andare al di là andare
oltre cercare di scoprire che cosa c'è
al di fuori di quello che conosciamo
quasi una spinta continua verso una
ricerca costante che è al di là di
quello che noi conosciamo oggi
potremmo quindi quasi pensare che
l'ambizione è una funzione crescente che
non si ferma mai che tende ad infinito
E no non è così semplice perché se ci
pensate se ci troviamo in una situazione
in cui l'ambizione cresce cresce cresce
può facilmente sfociare in quel troppo
che vedevamo prima ed essere definita ad
esempio
narcisismo arrivismo e quindi non
portare magari risultati che vogliamo
come facciamo quindi a capire dove
dobbiamo fermarci
rivolgiamoci ai numeri per capire meglio
34%. questa percentuale è la seconda
causa più comune di fallimento delle
startup secondo un recente studio di
cibi insights
e volete sapere qual è questa causa la
mancanza di un marketing
quindi stiamo dicendo che il 34% delle
volte delle startup Hanno raccolto
capitali sviluppato e lanciato sul
mercato un prodotto un servizio che in
realtà non aveva un cliente potenziale o
quantomeno un cliente disposta a pagare
Come è possibile direte voi guardiamo
degli altri esempi sempre facendo
riferimento ai numeri
1.8 billion il capitale raccolto da una
startup di video On Demand americana
chiamata Chibi fondata dall'excerman di
Walt Disney Studio Eco founder di
Dreamworks Animation quindi capite bene
una persona con un track record
incredibile
sei mesi la durata di questa avventura
che si è conclusa Insieme a tutta
un'altra serie di spiegazioni con la
dichiarazione finale del founder che
diceva non c'era un Market fit
un altro esempio
140 i caratteri che fino a poco tempo fa
si potevano utilizzare su Twitter
30 dollari il prezzo secondo cui il
fondatore di una start up americana
chiamata one hundred And Forty Canvas
gli utenti sarebbero stati disposti a
pagare per stampare su dei cartonati
Giganti the fake Twitch
Ecco capite bene che qui ci troviamo di
fronte a due esempi eclatanti dove
l'ambizione è diventata eccesso e non ha
portato in realtà al successo
quindi vediamo insieme quali possono
essere Questi elementi che ci possono
aiutare a trovare a trovare l'equilibrio
secondo la mia esperienza personale no
identificati quattro ovviamente e parto
col primo
accettare una fisiologica percentuale di
incertezza quindi di un comanserton con
l'esperienza mi sono resa conto che
ovviamente cercare di controllare tutte
le variabili non è possibile L'unica
cosa che possiamo fare è cercare di
capire quali possono essere e cercare di
gestirle
per me un esempio di questa situazione è
stato quando nel 2012 mi sono trovata a
cambiare lavoro
sono passata da una società che era best
place to work conosciutissima lo è
ancora Google quale Google per andare in
una realtà che al tempo era pressoché
sconosciuta Spotify che diceva nel 2012
di voler trasformare il fisico in
digitale quindi immaginatevi una realtà
come appunto Google che era
rinomatissima con vi ricorderete gli
uffici fantastici con gli scivoli le
poltrone massaggio per andare in una
realtà che al tempo non è che non
avessimo gli scivoli non avevamo neanche
gli uffici e questa è una storia vera
Quindi qua il messaggio è qualunque sia
lo step che vuoi fare devi sempre tener
conto di una percentuale di rischio Ecco
perché l'ambizione deve fare i conti con
una percentuale di U come un serpenti
maggiore di zero
veniamo al secondo elemento
lo rappresentato così radice quadrata di
E dove E sta per eGo
in realtà il messaggio qui è
l'importanza dell'essere umili
l'umiltà sembra una caratteristica in
totale contrapposizione con l'ambizione
ma in realtà non è così perché essere
consapevoli delle proprie capacità ci
permette di avere di porci degli
obiettivi Sì sempre più elevati ma
concreti raggiungibili Quindi in realtà
l'ambizione sana va di pari passo con
l'umiltà
e anche qua rivolgiamoci all'etimologia
della parola umiltà viene dal latino
humus Che significa terra Quindi stare
con i piedi per terra Quindi se
Riprendiamo quello che dicevamo prima da
una parte abbiamo l'ambizione che ci
porta in tutte le direzioni dall'altra
abbiamo l'umiltà che ci ricorda di stare
con i piedi per terra e se mettiamo
insieme questi due elementi creiamo
valore generiamo crescita come un albero
Tra l'altro secondo me l'umiltà appunto
che è una virtù che sembra un po' Antica
quasi dimenticata è attualissima la
Google stessa mi ha fatto uno dei
principi fondamentali della sua cultura
il Big in Gumball E anche lo stesso
ascoltare i feedback degli utenti per
poi dirigere le strategie è un esempio
perfetto di umiltà
Tra l'altro secondo me una parola che
rappresenta questo concetto al meglio è
il titolo di un recente libro di
hamilcaicy che parla proprio di
ambicious che è la crasi perfetta tra
humble e Ambition
veniamo al terzo elemento
la sommatoria dei consents intesi come i
vincoli come limiti perché sommatoria
perché in realtà l'ambizione può essere
potenziata e rafforzata tanto più
l'individuo che si trova davanti ad
affrontare
riesce a gestirli al meglio Se invece
non riesce ad affrontarli rischia di
rimanerne distrutto bloccato
anche qua voglio darvi un esempio
personale della realtà in cui sono oggi
dazn Quale può essere il limite più
impattante che una società di streaming
live i contenuti si può trovare ad avere
ovviamente lo stop dei contenuti e dei
campionati che ci siamo trovati a vivere
Nel 2020 quindi immaginatevi una
situazione in cui non avevamo contenuto
non avevamo accesso agli stadi non
potevamo ovviamente accedere neanche
agli studi né interagire direttamente
con le persone
Ecco in quella situazione lì Secondo me
siamo riusciti a realizzare
l'espressione perfetta di Creativity
loves con strains Infatti siamo riusciti
in pochissimo tempo a creare più di 200
nuovi formati utilizzando in una maniera
nuova e innovativa il catalogo che
avevamo rivolgendoci a nuovi contenuti
come ad esempio gli Sports e addirittura
creando delle cabine portatili che
utilizzavamo per registrare i contenuti
che mandavamo a casa
dell'intervistatori e dei giornalisti
Tra l'altro parlando di costrains
proprio perché la creatività va cercata
e l'ispirazione stimolata tante volte i
costraze si trovano proprio nei lati più
periferici della società dove abbiamo
magari vincoli di opportunità di risorse
economiche
ed è lì che tante volte vediamo il
muoversi quelli che sono dei nuovi Trend
di innovazione o di nuove idee che
stanno cambiando delle abitudini di
consumo degli utenti Quindi anche qui un
mio messaggio è Ricordiamoci di cambiare
prospettiva e di non guardare sempre in
un'unica direzione
veniamo al quarto ed ultimo punto che la
rappresentiamo con una bellissima
gaussiana Questa è la funzione
dell'errore di Gauss cosa sarebbe
l'inevitabilità dell'errore ormai
sappiamo che nell'innovare sbagliare è
inevitabile quello che dobbiamo fare è
saper riqualificare l'errore il
cosiddetto Fail Better
e anche qua vi racconto una cosa che mi
è successa quando mi sono trovata a
lanciare Spotify in Israele immaginatevi
mesi e mesi di preparazione di una
campagna su tutti i mezzi conferenza
stampa a reti unificate e il giorno del
lancio andiamo live con una serie di
materiali che avevano degli errori di
battitura il libro
vi lascio immaginare cosa è successo
quella mattina me lo ricordo ancora e
questo perché ovviamente alcuni dei
materiali erano stati realizzati con
delle tastiere UK Us che non avevano
tutti i caratteri ibrido e quindi
purtroppo qualcosa Si era perso in un
attimo eravamo tren topic su Twitter con
commenti prese in giro eccetera e lì la
chiave è stata da una parte ritornare al
concetto di umiltà che vi raccontavo e
dall'altro ovviamente cercare di reagire
velocemente non abbiamo tolto la
campagna ma abbiamo fatto una campagna
della campagna in realtà sfruttando
quello che era successo e dicendo che
noi eravamo nuovi nel mercato e volevamo
proprio imparare da loro ed eravamo lì
per ascoltare suggerimenti ed ecco
quindi che improvvisamente il tono era
cambiato e addirittura gli utenti ci
hanno incominciato a supportare a
suggerire delle scuole di libro per
dirvi come è andata
bene Abbiamo visto Quindi questi quattro
elementi che abbiamo detto ci possono
aiutare a trovare l'equilibrio Ma come
troviamo la combinazione giusta di
questo equilibrio la combinazione che
tenga conto del saper gestire
l'incertezza uno
dell'importanza di essere anche umili
talvolta
3 che ci ricordi anche il valore che
dobbiamo dare costrinse ai limiti che ci
troviamo di fronte
e 4 che tenga conto dell'inevitabilità
dell'errore
come troviamo il giusto equilibrio la
chiave di questa combinazione
siamo noi
Ognuno di noi ha la responsabilità di
capire qual è il punto di equilibrio
giusto tenendo conto di quelle che sono
le conseguenze delle proprie azioni su
se stesso gli altri l'ambiente in cui
operiamo per arrivare alla vera
ambizione di successo che mi piace
definire sostenible Ambition
sostenibile perché la consapevolezza ci
può portare più risultati positivi
domani
sostenibile perché in questo modo
possiamo raggiungere gli obiettivi Ma
rimanendo come nei piedi per terra e
sostenibile perché ci può permettere di
essere di volta in volta la migliore
versione di noi stessi Grazie
[Applauso]